hey everybody it's gary vaynerchuk i've
got my peeps watching live on ustream
right now
and you can see i'm on youtube and i'm
about to talk about something that
really caught my attention
um i saw a tweet out from alan stern
from center networks
montlicks link up center networks a
great website he also just taped my
keynote from the street yesterday
if you haven't seen that let's link that
up as well from the new york observer
that picked it up but what i want to
really focus
on is a howard stern six minute video on
youtube
mott link that up we got my main man
chris mott doing a lot of linking up
today garyvaynerchuk.com
we're gonna play this full six minute
video and i'm gonna jump in and interact
rewind a little bit this might be a 10
or 15 minute video
he's talking about something very
fascinating to me i think howard stern
at the top of the monetizing radio game
for the last two decades this is a very
telling video this has a lot of impact
on where the world's going
this cements a lot of things to me and
should cement a lot of things to you
i am absolutely pumped and honored to
call out
howard stern your game is lame my man
you are
past and i understand he capitalized i'm
not talking about what he's done
he crushed it he monetized he put the
hundred millies in the bank so i'm not
gonna dis on him he's absolutely
brilliant
as i'll point out in this video but the
game is changing my friends
and there's a lot of people crying about
it including the top
of the top let's listen to this this is
howard stern
the other day on september 17th
what's more popular social networking
sites or
pornography sites believe it or not i
have to think i'm taking a guess here
that the social my social network do you
mean my facebook my space
they put up everything in their lives
like someone gives a [ __ ] everybody's so
interesting
um but yeah yeah everyone's so
interesting you know what get a job
abroad we just got in here all right
let's start with where he's going right
now what he's doing is he's establishing
a situation where
you're not me you're not as good as i am
don't try to do what i do see stern's in
the radio game
and what bothers him about social
networks and web20 in general
is that anybody now can be in the game
see he had to with his wild style in the
70s or early 80s
had to get approved and how to have a
partner in crime a producer that
believed in him
nobody needs to do that anymore you just
put your content out there and you're
in the game and the ability to listen to
me or you or anybody else
is now equal discern actually stern
costs money now
cause he capitalized and cashed in and
good for him by the way i'll never hate
on making some cash um but anybody's in
the game now against stern and that
wasn't the case and what he's doing
right now is making sure that his
listener base doesn't
become ambitious and he's suppressing
their opportunity
to do what he does she's got everything
going on if you're on my face you're
right if you're on my face like he
doesn't know what it is
please this guy is brilliant if you're
on my facebook and you know
and you don't work shame on you because
that's hours you should be working
i mean really if you have to i like that
a little bit you know i like the hustle
i think you should be working but there
is a new way to work a new way to brand
and these websites sometimes are your
platform to do that time for that do you
have time to work would you answer my
question what do you want to know and it
is creepy
what what's more possible see what
you're doing you're trying to make sure
inside
those sites not the porn sites believe
it or not now porn is huge on the
internet but i believe people are so
concerned with
putting their own pictures up and
reading their own [ __ ] words
two people read that [ __ ] but uh once
again i believe it's the networking
once again a lot of people mock's
laughing he loves that two people read
that [ __ ] and that's true a lot of
people don't have the talent but guess
what
two people will listen to that [ __ ] on
the radio too if you suck
so if you're not good enough on the
radio you'll get cancelled
and been put away just like in his world
radio
in the online world video blogging
social network social media if you're
not good nobody's gonna watch
so you have to have the chops the
platforms have changed
not the rules so that's what he's trying
to establish and by the way
the reason he's guessing social networks
is because he's paying attention
he's not a clown he didn't get there
because he's an idiot he's actually
a brilliant self-brander marketer
promoter he did a phenomenal job
but so he's not just saying believe it
or not it's bigger than porn he's paying
attention
well internet researcher bill tanzer
analyzed information for more than 10
million web visitors and concluded that
young users
spend so much time on social networks
that they don't have time to look at
adult sites
my daughter's friends all do that but
they've been doing it
oh his daughter's friends right so he's
paying attention guys
we're 12. yeah and now he's saying 12
years old to make it seem like a kids
game
from 20 percent a decade ago now
myspace
you gotta admit that you look at your
friend's page
really so even if i want to look at
these pages i'm not gonna go on i'm not
gonna admit
are now on site such as myspace and
facebook
how does that happen like when you just
vote for your friends when you see your
friends out
you say if you want my opinion on the
democratic convention you can just go to
my blog
you know what it is pay attention here
every picture of themselves
they want to share themselves with the
world they put that
that's what he wanted to do you know he
talked about every thought
he told you about his mom he told you
about his dad he told you about his life
that's what he did every day i even see
like radio guys and [ __ ] they keep blogs
they're such [ __ ]
on the air you should that's your blog
don't you're gonna this is old school
right
he's old school he sounds just like your
dad
howard stern sounds like your dad the
great howard stern
is sounding like an old man to me right
today why he has vested financial
that's all they do is talk about their
lives on the radio
platform but he doesn't want you to do
it on the online platform which allows
you to reach more far more
people that need it plus you're
competing against a lot more people
anybody can do it
he just beat a couple of clowns
like he's so much better than the white
guy he's a rapper with a job
i hit on all of the girls and they all
rejected me because i'm a fat [ __ ]
ironic everything he's doing now
clowning the person that he's making
pretend
is the same thing howard stern did every
single morning
for 20 years everything he's making fun
of in that voice right now
is exactly what he did day to day and
that allowed you to get
interested in howard and he gave you
that connection what made stern popular
what made oprah popular was they didn't
just do their world they brought you
into their world
you knew about steadman you knew about
sturm's family the girls you knew about
that stuff that movie
it showed his life his parents he
brought you in that's what blogs are
doing
it's bringing people in and then you get
to make decisions of who you like and
who you think are interested
but now because it's using a platform
that he is not familiar with
or more importantly i think he's very
familiar with but is not positioned to
leverage
because of his situation and listen
again this guy killed it and won i'm not
disrespecting howard stern in any shape
or form
in his career he dominated it right it's
like a great 1970s basketball player
but let's take koozie from the 50s and
put him in the nba today
and i'm not so sold on how great he
would be
i'm talking to jeff carter he's such a
chore he has no vocabulary yeah i mean
he's like all his draining day and if
your day was that training gandhi you
wouldn't have time to write on the blog
you'd be exhausted you had to leave at 5
30 to get today
yeah exactly i think that was one on the
line do you have it there in front of
you no i don't i
was just trying to remember my face i
hate talking to stupid people
fat face yeah yeah it was kind of like
that it was like a classic
what's going on here it's like a really
rough day then we had to go to kansas
this is the same stuff he did every
single
day for 20 years he just hates the fact
that his section of that world is now
exposed to
everybody he's sad now he's a champion
up
you wanted everybody to know everything
about you all those years
and it was my last day there i guess my
friends do people
read about it people who care about me
that's what it says if i bring
pictures to my uncle's house they won't
look at it
howard stern is the exact same person
that would absolutely
dominate social media today if he was 20
years old and you know what howard
i got something to tell you you wouldn't
have had to share the revenue with all
those douche bags you've had to
for the last 25 years so honestly you
would have crushed it even more because
your skill set
is over the top and you're interesting
and your cost of entry would have been
zero and you would have been able to
come in
and nobody would have told you to shut
your mouth but
at the end of the day the fact that
you've already made it
and you've cashed in on your personal
brand and your skill set
very nice and the fact that you've
crushed it and made all this money
and did it and now you're standing on a
platform
and not encouraging people and putting
them down and trying to suppress
because you just want to be that ego in
your own mind that's how i look at him a
man honestly
because you don't want somebody to come
up the ranks and do what you did to don
imus to you is pretty [ __ ] sad
i'm just saying
i left k-rock right before the free fm
flip to go to work for the concert
promoter live nation that's somebody
having a conversation with me that's
somebody
that's used to working right now well he
has he has your voice for some reason
yeah
where is what you write where's your
blog that jason kaplan
it's it's for some reason facebook
changed and i don't know where i found
it all right yeah
so today was our final day of taping and
it started like every other day it's
unbelievable
everything single thing he's making fun
of which is what he built
his business on the fact of the matter
is howard stern
lives in old media and he doesn't like
it
because nobody's talking about howard
stern when's the la
you scream 156 people on you stream
right now i'm sorry i listen to rob
let's get them on the screen
when is the last time you heard somebody
talk about
howard stern honestly on a serious level
i mean
give me a yes no people talking are
people talking about howard stern
give me a yes no so far i see two years
ago a year ago stern equals a dinosaur
no no
when he got married no no here's a yes
no no no
no over his satellite radio deal i mean
that was what three years ago
no no no never
who is howard stern no no long time ago
months ago bubba bowie
when he went to satellite he sucks he's
over equals family now listen
these are people that are using ustream
in 2008
people that are using things like
twitter that's how they found out about
this time has passed for stern
and the next turn is going to be built
and you should go out and take it
don't listen to people like howard stern
that make fun of you
i think it's a waste of time i think if
you're over the age of 15 you shouldn't
be on it
he's trying to suppress people from
coming and taking a piece of his cake
he's scared and so are a lot of other
people don't listen to the haters
do it if you believe that you've got the
chops leverage the new media's because
there's no gay keepers
and crush it that's how
my face my head